Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome to "Don't Play This Game."
Now I'm gonna go play this game 'cause I'm a simple guy
When you tell me not to-
Game: Yᴏᴜ ʟᴀᴄᴋᴇᴅ ɪɴ ᴛʜᴇ ғᴀᴄᴛ ᴛʜᴀᴛ I ᴅᴏɴ'ᴛ ᴋɴᴏᴡ ᴡʜɪᴄʜ ғᴏʀ Pᴏsᴛ-Nᴏᴍᴏsᴛɪɴᴋ
Game: Wʜʏ ᴅᴏɴ'ᴛ ʏᴏᴜ ɢʀᴜᴇʟ ᴏɴ ɪᴛ?
Game: Sᴀᴍᴇ ғᴏʟɢᴇɴ ᴀs ᴇᴠᴇʀ.
Game: Hᴏᴄᴋ ᴏғ ᴛʜᴇ ᴛᴀʙʟᴇ ᴄʟᴏᴛʜ ᴘᴜɴᴛ.
Game: Dᴏ ʏᴏᴜ ᴜɴᴅᴇʀsᴛᴀɴᴅ ᴍᴇ?
Mark: No not at all!-
Game: Nᴏʙᴏᴅʏ ᴅᴏᴇs
Mark: Okay...
Game: Lɪsᴛᴇɴ;
Tʜᴇʀᴇ's ᴀ ʙᴏᴅɢɪɴs ᴀᴛ ᴛʜᴇ ᴅᴏᴏʀ. Sʜᴏᴜʟᴅ I ɢᴀʀᴇsᴛ ʜɪᴍ?
Markipier: I don't know what a-
Fɪɴᴅ ᴍᴇ ᴀ ɢʀᴏᴍᴘʜʀᴇᴀʟ.
Whaat??
Wha- I jus- That's the game?!
What, am I supposed to remember that?!
There's a garage at the guh- door?
Should you GAREST him?
I dunno what the fuck just happened!
Hang on everybody
I need to- I need to- I need to reset my brain because I have no idea what the hell just happened.
Oh my god okay
Listen again sure
* Tʜᴇ ɢᴀᴍᴇ ᴄᴏɴᴛɪɴᴜᴇs sᴘᴇᴀᴋɪɴɢ*
Markiplier: I lied in the fart?
Game: Wʜʏ ᴅᴏɴ'ᴛ ʏᴏᴜ Gʀᴜᴇʟ ᴏɴ ɪᴛ?
Sᴀᴍᴇ ғᴏʟɢᴇᴏɴ ᴀs ᴇᴠᴇʀ.
Game: Dᴏ ʏᴏᴜ ᴜɴᴅᴇʀsᴛᴀɴᴅ ᴍᴇ?
Markiplier: NOOOOOOOOOOOO!!!!!
Game: Nᴏʙᴏᴅʏ ᴅᴏᴇs...
Markiplier: You- I do!
Kinda...
Game: LISTEN;
Markiplier: There's a bodgins at the door?
Markiplier: V-gromph, WHAT ABOUT BEAR GRYLLS?!
Two thirty eight out of seven eighty?! I don't know what you're doing to me!
What is ""TSKLMTEFLXGHIXNKVWON..."
"...SWDOEHJWPG-"
*coughing*
What does that mean?!
So are any of you guys writing this down because I feel like there's gotta be a quiz at this end of this and-
I didn't know we were gonna get onto, heh, ourselves into the S.A.T's here but here we go again.
*Tʜᴇ ɢᴀᴍᴇ sᴛᴀʀᴛs ᴀɢᴀɪɴ.*
Markiplier: I lit my fart on fire.
Markiplier: I eat my gruel every day.
Markiplier: Ah Folgers, the best part o' waking up-
Markiplier: Uhuh, uhuh punt the tablecloth, got it
Markiplier: Uhhhh, I think I do I'm getting it-
Game: NOʙᴏᴅʏ ᴅOᴇs.
Markiplier: I do
Markiplier: Okay theres ten beavers at the door-
Markiplier: Should you- sh-should you garasthem??
Markiplier: Find you a game grump?
[Markiplier sighs]
There's seven hundred and eighty okay, lets just concentrate on the numbers that I- it's given me here.
The seven hundred and eighty, might be the sheer number of letters in the phrase that whatever the hell that demon spawn is saying.
So if we think about it that way, we're only getting two hundred and thirty two of the correct letters out of that?
Is that an understandable way to go about this?
Or is that going about it the wrong way?
What happens if I quit?
H̶̵͇̰͒ͪͫ͗̒͡͞͏̷̛̠̉̾҉͏͗͊Ȇ͚̲̹̒̿͝͠͏͐͆ ͍͙̞̐ͤͣI̺̺͉̾̒̚S͙̒͗͢͡ ̨͇̲̘͕̂H̵̷̶̡͇͙͉̃̒̿̾͌͒͢ͅĘ̣͎̞̘͛̿ͧ͐́ͯͮ̒ͨ͏̶͔̑ͮ͡҉͔̺̳͋̀͒̆R̷̡̦͓̰̟͖̦̬͔͊̌͗͊͋̅ͮ̂̈́̆ͨͤ́ͣ̽̊ͪ̐̃͒̚͟͡ͅE̢̪̘̜͔ͣ͋̾̓͏̷̥͉̹̘͐̽ͥ͗͞.̮̄͌̊ͭ ̨̘̤̻̟̬̻̪̦͆̒̔ͭ͐̔̑̏͗̾͒D̛̟͉̖̊̂̏̓͝O̴̩̜͚ͣͬͭ͠N͎̰̱̮̙̣͔̬͖̲͑ͬ͑́̾̅̽͘͡͡͡'̢̌T̵̸̺͊ͮ̒ ͔̺͓̯͊͐M̢̧̰̗̙͎ͫ͢A͕͙̖̭̝ͭ̾̿ͦ̾̓̇͠K̺̖̣̞ͯͯE̶̻̫͕̣̦̫̮͇̙̦͉̲ͪͨ͐̿̍̿ͅ ̧̗̬͒̃ͣ̓ͮ͗͗ͯ͋ͧ͑̅̅̿͟͠͞T̫̭̻̟͈ͥ̏H̸͛ͬ̅̋̋̿Ę̡̳̪͖̈̑ͮ͒̆̃ͥ̌ͣͯͬ͟͜͜͟͠ ̶̻͓͓̪͔̝̉̏̇̃ͭ̌̂͑͒̈́ͭ̒̕̕͡Ḑ̶̯̭̣̻̺̩ͤ̓̄͒̎̒ͭ̚͢E̠̙̻ͫ̎̇̌̄͘A̡̢̞̤͈ͥ̈̅̂͜͡L̷̸̹̙ͤͬͬ̈́ͤ̀̓͜ ̨̧͔̦̖̲̖͙̏̏ͭ́̑͒́WͦI̧̛͉̘̠͉͙͈̟̯ͤ͛ͦ̓̈́ͯ̀̈̕Ţ̴̟̹̲̗ͤͮ̄̓̏ͭ͛̃̊̂̅ͤ̋̑̓͛͘͝͏̶̟̦͆Ḣ̠̺͐͢ ̸̰̠͕̱̘̤̇̒H͈̎̆͗͞͠Ǐ̧̹̠͎̓͘Ṁ̢̥̮̩̍͂͂̔ͫ ̧̥͎͖̘̠͙̜̱ͥͣͪ̒͊ͮ̏ͨ̂͐ͨ͘̕͢͟͞D̸͕̈ͥ̆ͮ̚O̧̡̻̲̘̝̜̪ͩͮ̋̎̐̌͐ͬͩ҉̃̈́̃͡ ̸̜͈̝͈͉̯͉̺͖̐̓̏̐͡͠Ņ̠̫͉̘̟̟̝̘̩ͯͫ̇̂ͫ̔̓͊ͮ̒ͯ̐̑ͦ̚͟O̩͓͉͎͔̺̽̔̇ͭ͑ͨ̽̍̅͜͟Ṫ̴̪͈̣̯̊̈́͋͊͂͌͂͑̓͘̕ ̻̬̮̦҉͇̞̖͚͈̞̎̎̀ͭͮ̑ͯ͏̫̻͂ͩ͞J̴̵̡̨͔͈̪̩̱̳̜͍̬̀́͌͒̑̆ͧ́̀́ͫ̍͝͞͝O̶͖̝̩̪̭̙̠͆͆́̽͋̄ͦͤͯ̈͛̆͋̚I̢͉͎̖̠̬͇͙̼͚͂̾̓̕̕ͅN̴̨̮̠͓̾́̊̽̄̿͜ͅ ̨͈̯̭͙̪̖͆̀̂̔̽̽̏͟͡H̡̳̻̞̫̀́̆̑ͩ̈̄ͬ͘͢͝͏̸͎ͤͪͪ͆͞Ē̴̠̤̲̭̲ͤͧ̓̐͠L̬ͨ͊͋͆P̸̮͇ͤ͑ͦ͒̀́͟͞ ̵̲̭̟̰̱͒ͪ͛ͤ̓̏͂̓̉͘҉̸̀ͅÄ̺͇̜͈̦̼́ͥ͑҉̣͑ͦ̄̐N̖͈̮̩̏͗̈́̆͂͑ͧ͘͟Ḍ̷̻͎̲͙ͩ͂̒́͘ ̮̆̒̄   S͞AV̨E̝ ẎO͑U̻R͏SE͠LF͋
Oh the game ends.
Ha! Well, that's dumb for me, because that is- that's not what I was aiming for lets try that again!
Ima go back in here! I'm gonna go back in, I don't know howta play this game!
Cuz who the frick knows what that all is?
Let's give her a listen
*̡ T͒ʜ̤ᴇ̰ ɢ͕ᴀ̴ᴍᴇͥ ʀᴇᴘ̬ᴇ̊ᴀᴛs̀ ͮɪ̬ᴛ̜s̰ᴇʟғ̵ ͝ᴀɢ̳ᴀ̰ɪ̶ɴ*̓
Mark: Hi! Oh. "HIGNM"
Markiplier: [Trying to pronounce string of text on screen]
Markiplier: Cthulu is coming!
Ima write down, what this persons saying
Ima write down the words
It may take me a few goes but I'm gonna try to write it down
Maybe I can make sense of it that way
Markiplier and Game, in unison:
Can you enlighten the fact, I don't know which for sim-pasta mosting?
Both: Why don't you gruel on it?
Both: Same foldgen as ever
Both: Hover the tablecloth punt
Dͭ̍ͭᴏ̯̀ͬ ̻ͧʏᴏᴜ̣́҉ ̉ᴜɴ̟͓̝ᴅ͟ᴇʀ̈́s̬ͫ̄ᴛᴀ̸̤ɴ̅ᴅ̌͏̲ ̓҉ᴍ̔ᴇ̓̑?
Nǒbody̦ ̬d̍oeͨs.̑
Li̒sten;
T͋hͥe͊re̝'s ̋a ̓b̌odg̮in͐s aͨt ̭t̟he͐ doo͠r.̢
Sho̍uld͋ I ͥg̎ar̞e̓s̍t̜ him?
Find ̟mͮe ͧa̬ ģromͫph̲ ͎reilͩ
Yo̕u̒ ͏l͏̵̕a͋u̷ͮgh͎͇͢eͭd i̦͜n ̷̭̟th̍̚e̳ f̯̺̐a͙̅ct̖ ͥ͠͡t̖̹haͤͩt̶̬ ͏̈͟I̢ͦ͡ d̃͟ȯ̥n'ͦͥt̜̐ k̉͆n̫ͧo͒͠w͎͛̕ ẃ̡̕hi̬c̩h̛̩͂ ͈̑̕p̄̿os͘͏t̉̃-̓No͟m̞̎͂os̑t̵͑i͖͜n͚̲͐k͍̿̕.͓
W̢̩hÿ̮ ̶͓do͘n̠̓̃'̭̔̿t҉ y̧̑͋o̰ȕ̮͔ ̌g͖̣̅ruĕ̵l ͫ̚o͘n ĩ̻̍t?͇
͜Sͮ͡ḁ͙me̔̕ fo̤̫͒l̼d͝g̩ͨ̂e̬͏n̜̔͡ ǎs ̸͚ev̔͡ẻ̪̪r
̀͊͞
̏H́̀o͕͆̐g͕̏͠ ̾͋͞ỏ͍f ̾̀ṱ̈́̓h̙̀e̻̝ͤ t̯̉a̟ͤ̚bl̢͛̉e̝͋͜cͥl͜o̸̟͉t͔̊h̵ p͓un̰tͮ̑͘.
̴D͍͖̰o̗ yo̼͛̋u̴͠ ̀͂un̫̼͊derst̻͐ä͙́͟n̢̥d̝͗ ̾̒ͪme̗̲͗?̆
͙Nͪob͖ͫo͞dy͍̐͘ doės̡̙̓.҉̌̽
L̊̉is̛te͍̪͛n̞͗;̾ͭ͡
Tḣ͌e͡r̖e͗'s a ̽bͭo͋d̿̚ǵ̡̹in̏s ̴̈́at tͮ̚h̻͎ͅe̥ͭ ̛̯͊d͈o͇or̐.ͮ̌̌ S̷̅͘h̞o̢͇̖ư̓͐l̺d͔ ̨ͬ́Ì̲̃ ̞ͯg͚̝̤a̧̭ͥr̷͒esṱ͎ ̘̍̚hi͔͎m?̗́
̛̯̟F͉͒i͆̆͋n̞̖ͮd̜ͭ͊ ̈́m̼͘͏e̝ ̅ͣa͘ g̳̺ͨr̹͋ó͟͠m̤̉p̿͜͜hr̮e͔̥il͏̞͗
Markiplier: One ninety-nine!
"VINQETAIAQWWVOMDBLGWQPNSTITWMQ"!
I don't know what this is!
(gentle creaking in the background)
You laughed in the fact that I don't know which post-Nomostink.
Y̔o̱̫̅uͤ ͒l̮̇au̎gȟ̨̲e̴͎̽d̐ ̠̮͂ḭ̧҉n̅ ͇̯ͦt̆ĥ̡͟e̬͉͍ f̉̋a̱̾̏c̜̔t͇̃ͧ ̹͖͋tẖ̈́͋a̢͖͋t ̊ͥͫI ̅do̳̽͜ṅ̳̇'ẗ̴̙ ̤k͉̚nớ̍w̗ ẃ͈̤hĭc̼̓h̰ͪ ͇pó̧̨st͏-̸̀͞N͠o̧mͣ̎͞o͂s̶̸͠ṫ̹̪ink.̷͌
Y̔ͅo̱̫ͬ́̅uͤ ͒ͬl̮̇̕au̎gh̨̲ͦ̈́̌̂e̴͎̽̓d̞̐ ̠̮̈́ͤ͂̄ḭ̧͟҉n̜̅̂ ͇̯̆ͦt̆ĥ̡͙̀͟e̬͉͍ͫ͟ f̉̋ả̶̱̓̾̏c̞̜̔t̨̘͇͚̃ͧ ͈̹͖͋tẖ̥̈́̾͋a̢̢͖̣͋t̵ ̊̔ͥͫỈ ̙̅d̹o̳͋̽͊͜ṅ̳̇'ẗ̴̙̟ ̤k͉̞̈́̚nơ̛̑́̍w̗͔ ̀w͈̦̤ͣ́h̯ĭ̻͍c̼̓̿h̰ͪͪ ͇po̧̨̐́s̗t͏͏-̸̠̀͞N̞͠o̧ͥmͣ̎͞o̓͂s̶̸͠t̲̹̪ͯ̇ink.̷͌
Y̘̔ͭo̱̫͔̅͡ụͤ ͒̚͢l̜̮͎̇aͨu̎̈gẖ̨̲̌͡e̴͎̓̽d̥̪̐ ̛̠̮͗͂ḭ̧͂҉̑n̅ ̘͇̯̇ͦt͓̆͡h̡̼ͨ̂͟͝e̬͉͍ f́̉̋a̱͕ͬ̾̏ͬc̜̔t͏̡͇̃ͧ ̨̹͖̭̐͋t͡h̫̱̏̈́͋a̢͖͖͋͝tͣ ̻̊ͥͪͫI ̧̅do̳̽ͭ̕͜n̳̺̄̇̇'͉ẗ̴̹̙ ̭̤̌k͉̀̚n̽ơ̯ͬ́͋̍w̗ ͨẃ̧͈̤̏hĭc̼̎̓h̰͍̰ͪ͟ ̖͇ͥpó̧̨͛̇sͫt͖͏͂-̸̣̻͐̀͞N̨͠o̧ͨ̊m̻͊ͣ̎͆͞oͧ͂ͬs̶̸͠t̻̹̪ͬ̇ḭnk̈.̷͌ͤ
W͋h҉y do̅n'̈ṭ ͫYͤOU ͙GRUE̺L̸ ONͯ I͓T?
Ẃ͋͟h҉ͮy̘ ̼d̑o̧̅n'̡̈t͕̣͖ ̛̑ͫYͤO͌U̹ ͙GR̜UĖ̺L̸̹ ON̜ͯ ͛I̛͓T̋?̓
Ẃ͕̻͋͟h̞҉ͮỵ̘ ̼ḏ̑o̧̟̅n'̡̈͋t͕̣͖̹̀͞ ̛̫͓̑ͫ͜Y̜ͤO̶͊͌U̼̹ ̷̼͙G̊R̜ͯͯU͐E̺͌̌̇L̸̶̹ ̏O͊N̜ͮͯ͞ ͬ͛I̛͓̿T̯̭̋?ͮ̓
S̴am͑e fol͊d͝gęo͘n ąs e͝v́e̹r
S̴̍ąm͑e͊ f͂ŏl͊ḑ̷͝gę͉͆o̓̌͘nͩ ąs ḙ͝v̄́e̹͋r.̖̝
S̝a̫mͬe ̼f̑o̩ldèon ͆as͍ Ｅ̞̦̊̀͂ͥ͊Ｖ̌̒Ｅ͒̆͏̩͟Ｒ．̡̗̖ͭ͂́̚．̰͈̊．̟ͥͦ̚͞
H̡o̷̮̚g o̷̍f̧͓ ̟͊̊t͠h͘e͗ ͂ͬt͓̎a̹̙b̭̲̅le̮͋c̐̓l͈̺o̥͟t̞̆̀h ͐p̹͑unt̻̖̱
H̡̆̇͘o̷̘̫͉̮͓̿͗̍̚͝g ͆̿̒o̷̷̧̪̯ͤ̍ͭ͐ͨf̴̨̧͓̜ ̷̯̟͊ͦ̊tͪ̉ͫ͠ḣ̿͘ĕ͚͍͗ ̿̓̂͂͗ͬ͑t͇̙͓̻̔ͪ̎ą̹̙̭̣̄b҉̵̶̭̲̩͐̅ͫ̏̚l͔͍̉e̮͋ͣc̵̐̊̓̉l͙͈̺̈́͆ͅȍ̷̥̥͎͚̌͟t̞̆̐ͨ̀̕҉̑͟h͚̍̊ ͉̲͐ͯp̜̹͒͋͑͊ͨuͩñ̡̕t͍̻̖̱̮̲̉̾
Ḩo͚g̖͐ͣ ̵̘͆o͉̗̽f̷̤͙ ͑͘̚tͮ͏̐h͘ę̜̀ taͧ͜͡bͯl͕e̫c̲lot̟h pͪunT̛.̨
Do you understand me?
D͎o yo͢ụ ̉unͩd͚er̿st̪and meͦ?
N͚
N͚oͮ͊
N͚oͮ͊b
N͚oͮ͊bo̙̩
N͚oͮ͊bo̙̩d̈͏
N͚oͮ͊bo̙̩d̈͏y do̔ͥ͌͏ę̍ͨ͜͏s.̡ͭ
L̗̤ͨ̓ḭs̍͝t͕̍ͨͣen̡̙͛̋̏,̧͐͞
t̫̫̹ͩ͢h͐é̞͠r̥̫̙͚ͅe'ͮs̴̻̀ͦ̆ ̶̫̻̪a̵̜ͥ̉͘ ̛̳͔̍͝bod̽ͦ̎g̷̡̮i̱ͬͮn̙̫̾s͙ͭ̈͢ a͈̿t͚͉͚̀͟ ͓ͧ͆t̸̛ͩh̗̋̓͘ȅ̱̻͒ ̈́̔͘d̖o̔̅͜o͖̹̅r.
Sḩ̬͕̯o̧̼ul̓̕d͞ ̾ͮ͋I ̤͈͊g̵̫̀͗a̵ͬr͈ͪ̎̕e̓̇st ̜ͦ͛̑̅h̚i͙m̹̀?̟͒ͨ̇͠
F͐i̶n̺͎̔̓ͨḏ̢̔̀ ̰͉̘̅̎̃m̵̡̦̣̬̊͆̂͠҉e̙ ͗̿ą͚̗̌͆̑͗̚ ̘̤̖̬͓̟̀͌ͮ̀g̵̻ͦ͒͘ṙ͉̿ù̩̟͚̻̯̓̿ͣͭm̧̟͒ͪ̊ͯͮ͋̅͟p̶̠͍͆ͫ̒͞ ͦ̀͌f̧͍̲̒͌ͨ͒͆̎͟r̶̡̲͈͐̊i̸̛̗̓e̪͇̜̱͔̓́ͨ͠l̴̙̒̔͡.͈̲ͭ
D̘ͮ̍̇̀ ̿o͙̟ͫ̃ ̮҉̒ͮ̕ y҉̣̖̯̞̌̅ ̵̯̃̽̀ͣ̀͝o̬ ü̱̻̦̓̓̓͆̑͡ ̵̜̹͎͇́̽̿̽͢u̳̰͌ͬ͋ ̝͍̻͞n̂ ̽d͇͍̫̕͠ ͫe̔̈̂͜ ̴͉ͬr͍͏ ͂͊͊̚͟s͓̩̔̉ t̹ͭ̂̆ ̶͎͡a̢̍͂ n͙͖̙̑̇ d ͊̽͑ ͐̆̀ ̵ͫ̀  ͔  ͓̊ͦ͐ ́ͮ̎̚  ̚ ͆̓̍͆  ̡͙̿̀͠m̙̀̇̎ę͎͈̰͔ͥ͛̀͌͆ͣ͛͜͞?̸̧ͧ
Ṅ̷͔̫̤͖̪̟̟͒͆̈́ͪ͌ͭ͟ ̝̲͎ͤ̔ͥ̓̂ͧͭ͒̎̓̃ͥͫͮ̋͘̕ŏ̹ͤͤ͊͠ ̷̱̰̖̲̭̲͙ͦͪ̃̍ͥͯ͌b̴͖̩̻̎ͩ̐͢ ̘͛̓ͦ҉̵̶̢̹̦̹̞̄̀̾ͭ͋͠o̴̡͕͍͂̇ͫ̓̔͡ ̷̫̪̥̻̳͖ͥͯ̈̃̆̓͘̕ḓ̵̨̥̭̝̮̯̗̭͛̓̉͌͑̅̕͠ ͎̜̤́́̌ͣ͊ͩ͆̓y̨̖͏͎͖̀́͌ͮ̏̀ ͖̯ͬͯ̌̒͌̀͢͝͞ ̨̛͇̲͔̜̺̹͈͈͛͆͊́̾̕͜ͅͅ ̗̎ ̶͔͚̱̱̀ͦ͆̓ͤ̑͆̓ͮ͋͟͞d ̵͍̘͐͗͂̉ǫ̶̧̟̹͙͖̱ͧͤ̈̀ͪ̌ͦͭ̎ͭͪͮ ̢̠̜̲ͮͭ͊͆͋̒͟͞҉e̜͉̮͙͌ͨ̾̿ͦ̾̕͡ ̠͚̗ͩͮ̊̇̽̋͂ͣ͢s̵̡̪͗̾͌ͨ.͟͞͏
N͖̝ͩ͏̵̷̡̢̨̡̢̨̡̖̻̟̗͚̣̬̯̣̖̖͈͈̺̩̞͈̣̞̼̦̗̙̖͙̜͔̯̞̳̮̪̜̬ͫ̊ͭ̌ͩ̔̿̏̀͐ͦ͗͊̉͒̐̒͌̎̉̇̿ͧͫ̎͐͐ͦ̈́ͥ̑͑̿̀̌́̐̈̂͑͗ͪͨ̓̀̉͘͘͘̕͜͡͝͠͠Ơ̴̸̵̡̢̢̢̧̨̛̘̯̙̤͈̣̼̟̺͕͙̟͈̻̻̪͉͈̻̲̺̱̘̩̼̟̗̦͈͕̥̯͓̪͇̙̾̏̇͐͋͑̓͐̅̔̿ͥ̍ͨ̿̒̄͌͛ͥ͊̆̔̿̊̐͆̓͆͌̉̂ͣ̀ͥ̆͑̌͟͟ͅ͏̶̧͓̳̪͕̘͓͐ͭͬ͋͊͞B̸̶̷̡̛̟̞̫͉̹̮̳̲̩͉̪͎̮̰̩̼̥̦̥͖̘̠̤̥̱͉̝̪̗͎́ͬ̒̔́ͮ̉̎ͨ͌̌́͆̉̈́ͭ̑͋̊ͪ̿ͭ̒̿̾ͧ̂ͮͧ̀ͧ̎ͯ́̅ͧͨ͐̓͛͋͒̓̏̊ͧͨ̾ͦ̐ͬ͗̽̈͘͘͢͢͝͏̵̧̡̗̘͓̰̣̭͍̿̇̍͂ͯ̆͋̿̄̇ͣ͗͡͞҉̥̝͗͟O̡̮̪̜̗͇ͦ͗̋ͤ͗͏̸̵̷̶̴̢̡̧̛͙̥̺̰̯̺͉͙͙̥̖̖̳̗̘̱̘͉͙͇͔͓͉̩̩ͫ͗̎͋̊͋̀͂̊͒ͭ̊͌̿̌̀̌̆̃ͮ̓ͥͦ͊̊͐ͣ̐͛̐ͨͮ̏ͯ̒͊͂̈́̑̊ͭ̈̌̕̚̚̕͢͠͡͡ͅ҉̵̷̣͙̯͓͚̫͆ͯ͗ͯͧ͊̒̄̓͗̎͜҉͔̞̪̭̠̱͕̓̓͊͌̎̎҉̶̧̨̛̪̝͎̜̳͖̠͇͇͎͇̩̰̺͎̤͖̞̲̹͍̙͎̼̞̈́ͥ͗̀̆̆ͪͯ̉̇͛ͯ́̐̀̚̕͝͠ͅͅD̵̷̨̼̰̹͉̮̥̞̣̩͍̗͆͗̑̀̇ͪ͌ͬ͊ͫ͆̊͠͝҉̴̣̙̘̫̥̘̹̭̯̺͎ͭ́͛͐͊̾̐̏ͭͩ̔̑ͮͫͤ̚̚͘̚͢͏̧̛͔͎̥͇͖̃̐͆̀͌͜҉͙̗̑҉̴̡̰̘̘̱̯̗̏ͤ̏͊̎͟Y̴̶͓̯̙̗̱͚̞̣ͬ͑́̀̒͗̍́ͣ͆ͩͦ̑̒͘͠.̵̛̳̭̟͔̗̮̩̪̬̬̻́ͤͦͤ͂͂ͬ͑ͭ̔̋ͬͫ̒ͦͦ̆͒͋̌͘̕̕͢͞͡͝҉̶̵̳̲̬̤̬̞͚̞͒ͦͪ͛ͣ̐̀̏̌͑͗̈̑̐̂́ͨ͏̟̟̹̐͑͋͋́ͪ̄̋̿̆̿̅͜͝͞҉̴̶̢̺̩̲͔̥͈͍̟̭͎̲̖̹̙̯͙̭̓̊ͥ͂́̊́͐͊̿ͫ̽̆́̒̐̚͘̕͞҉̸̠̯ͯͨ҉̴̶̨̧̣̬̗̘͙̲̬̼̦͉͙̱̳̱̩͎͇̗͉̖̼̜̫ͥ̉ͦ̽̍̇̿ͥ̊ͫ̂̈̎̿ͮ͂̅͋̂́̽̑́̽̾̈̆̑͑͒͘̕͜͟͢͠͡͞ͅͅ
[Mark's voice back to normal]
Okay, I have no idea!
I have absolutely no idea what to do with this! There's no other information being given to me,
It's the same words everytime.
So it's not like the words are changing
I really don't know what to do about this so I'm gonna leave it up to you guys!
So, I know it says don't play this game but I'm gonna put a link down for the game below
And uh, hopefully you guys are going to be able to solve the mystery
But be careful not to L̟̭̺͑͂ͩ҉̸̷̟̖̦̬̙̅̌̓OS͛̽ͅE̵͍̱̣̖ͧ̄͌͜͠ ̸͖͛ͪ̅̊͟͝҉̶̢̤̟͚͖̓ͬ͒ͭẎ̵̷̶̫͈͙͎̮̼̇́ͬ͛ͪ̿͘O̸̖̰͂͗͞Ù̖̈́͐ͪ̕R҉̦ ͖M͎̫̾ͬ͜͠Ḯ̶͕̠̖̗̓̐ͣ̎ͩ͞Ṇ̶̷̦͍͎̬̊̾̇ͬ̌ͭ͜͟D̸̺͔̐̌͒̅̆͏͇̙̖̘̭̥ͦͣ̇͛̑S~̡̟͙͎́͆̈́!̨̝̱̼ͣ͊̚!͂!
While you're diving down that hole.
So thank you everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video!
[ringing and creaking sound]
B͙uḩ͈͓̭̱ͭͤ̀҉̨͎̃͏̥̯̬-͈̪̗̫̝͉̤ͪ͆́̅͊̚͢͟ ̲b̸͙̣̭ͧ͗́ͫyę̸͚͓ͤ̀̿ͫ͊̐̄̐̍̍!̴̇̆͝